カメラのレンズを買いました今日は弾み冊です
広くなったなぁはいだけど今日の動画は皆さんですね
めっ
者とかすっ
空港んっ
tonic 食べる人たまにいませんか何かこう物事大きく表現する際に使われる言葉
としてすごくとか本当にとかめっちゃ
とかあると思うんですよこの言葉をつけただけですごくその物事が大きく見えます
例えば可愛い人がいたら可愛いじゃなくて
すごくかわいいとか
本当に可愛いとか言ったほうが可愛いさの音ブレ感じで1段階目に何回も上がるんです
よですがその後さらに可愛い人が入ったらすごく可愛いと言っても同じレベルになっ
ちゃうんですよ
その人が可愛い未定ときに使う表現が
国可愛い
本当に可愛い24にハワイイすごくかわいい
すっ
国かワイプ3段階に分かれると思うんですよね僕も多いさんな表現するときもちろん
素手使いますしみなさんも何か本当にすごいものを表現した時はえっ
努力っていう表現を使うと思いますで今日はその
の限界に迫ってみようと思いますこの機2分木杭と付き合いが長い人とかよくしてる人
がやるとあーなんかこいつふざけてるなぁとってバカにされるんでなんか最近やっと
話し始めた畑の新メンバーのてっちゃうとは敵の新メンバーのオーディションに落ちた
またぞうくんその2人のここにいるとすごいなが3基
まずくなると思うのでそのまだそんな中よくない3人で並んでボケがすっごくの小さい
つをどこまで伸ばせるかどうかそっと実験してみようと思いますさあそしてですねこの
ヤキソバン神目
あおいしいんですよというでこの焼きそばのを言ったをターゲットに伝えていきたいと
おもいます
れ y 校を含む4
[音楽]
いい
お山でてんだと思っています
pop を
タブ教
それいけません
pr
それかん
[音楽]
me いっ
気まずいやちゃまずい
やつ畑受かった人と買うか来ない人で大切だというかも
2絶望ができしいる席に小屋を破っているか
[音楽]
うーんこういうと仮面
だが
時間と思ったと思ったっ
僕らだけを言ってる感じですよねー
あれ
源さん
始めさ
再生
だめだ何かが絶対トリガーになってるはずなんで
何だろうなめっ
茶
多分絶対あるですよ何か言うと動き出すみたいなやつなんですよ
絶対そうだ駅蘇我パーンえっ
ラーメンなんだ朝ですよ
ねばエコままでや
源さんもずっと個まとめてしまうだかなーっ
影響に動かなくなっちゃうさ
ありましたん
ねっ
地元左折ですよ動かなくなるのに
これを吸ってい
決意ステップです
じゃあ保育園じゃこれうーん
ねぇめっちゃうまかったこれね
止まってましたよ始めで止まってないかもってない
ちょっと待ってますよちょっと待ってないと思う仮名ですかえっちょっとっ
まあ好きですして
ファー好きなんだなんだった
れちゃうお前さぁねっ
麺打ち聞いたらからをんでちょっと塗って
同じ動きキャロウェイと
あーこれ
多分
をしっかり使うん
おっ
ええええ
[音楽]
そうですよ
実は上釣ってるやん1着とってますねいっしょ
ねっちゃてるじゃんかどうすんのそれダイエットしたやんちょっとしたい
うん
[音楽]
6室うまい飯お願いをしています
いやもう翻訳側も表すとでも
めっ
床名前絶版めぇ名がポリなぁなんだな
[音楽]
んはぁっ
誘導がなった
小松考えた方が解決に撮っちゃうかもしれん
[音楽]
僕らも呼ばれているということを絶対何かしらの意図があった
ウッディ握手しておきますえっ
[音楽]
ええええええ
政府
[音楽]
ダウン帰ってみます
ガーン
席を外してみますかそう
ん
[音楽]
じゃあおいしいよねーあれっ
me
うううう
car
あっはぁ